so here's a statement you should have
issued joe you should have said
i called draymond green a knuckle
dragger because i wanted to imply that
he's stupid and obnoxious which he is
the same could be said about the
outraged mob lying about me and calling
me racist i do not believe that any of
you drama queens and phonies are
actually offended and whether you are or
aren't i do not apologize
god bless
[Music]
today we have many cancellations to hand
out all revolving around a local fox
weatherman in memphis named joey
sullipic
now why do we need to talk about a
weatherman in memphis i mean what could
he possibly have done to warrant
discussion well according to the media
he did a tweet not just any tweet but a
racist tweet indeed the headlines and
there are a lot of headlines about this
weatherman's tweet all agree that the
tweet was racist and that he is racist
and that he likely holds clan meetings
in his basement every tuesday just to
give you an idea here are some of the
headlines um
just reading a few memphis
meteorologists under fire over racist
draymond green tweet
local tv meteorologist memphis sparks
furor with racist comments about
warriors draymond green
memphis tv station promises
investigation after meteorologists sends
racist tweet about warriors draymond
green
draymond green is the target of memphis
meteorologist rachel slur
and then fox 13 tv weatherman makes
stunningly racist comment about draymond
green
now you'll notice that none of these
headlines use the word alleged or
purported or possible
if they use any qualifier at all it's
stunning
they simply assert that he used a racial
slur and that's the end of it no further
discussion necessary
but if you're wondering what the man
actually said as if such a detail even
matters anymore here's the new york post
article it says a memphis based
meteorologist is under investigation by
his employer for using a racial slur in
a tweet about warriors star draymond
green amid the grizzlies warriors
playoff series fox 13 memphis chief
meteorologist joey sullipec who is white
tweeted the following after game three
get ready for this
uh chew on this draymond runs his
knuckle-dragging open mouth all game
long but mild-mannered kyle anderson
disputes one call and gets ejected next
level jackassery
and then it says sullipic reportedly
deleted the tweet after facing backlash
and he later deleted his entire twitter
account so
that's it
did you spot the racism
probably not seeing as how he didn't say
anything even remotely racially charged
he used the term knuckle dragging to
describe green that's a common
expression
a kind of cliched insult often applied
to people of all different races and
meant to imply that they are as the
oxford dictionary defines the term a
stupid or loutish person
the dictionary makes no mention of any
racial connotation much less does it say
that the term is a racial slur
in fact it has never in my life even
occurred to me to interpret knuckle
dragger in a racist way
and it's still not immediately clear to
me why it would be racist aside from the
simple fact that it's an insult and we
live in a culture so incredibly stupid
that literally any insult of a black
person is immediately assumed to be
racist
but is there more behind it than that
here's an article on the sports news
site marca.com and it provides this
explanation this is what they say
the term knuckle dragger has long been
used by bigots to describe an angry
black man it is meant to compare them to
a large and enraged ape such as a
gorilla
wait what since when has knuckle dragger
meant that
i have literally not once in my entire
life ever heard anyone use it in that
context
in fact as is so often the case in these
kinds of situations you would have to be
extremely racist to actually see the
term as racist
if you hear knuckle dragger and
immediately think oh he must be saying
that black people are apes
then it's you who harbors deeply racist
thoughts and ideas within yourself
that's what's known as projecting
ironically we see again how the alleged
racist villain is actually being
penalized for not being racist
the weatherman is so not racist that it
never so much has crossed his mind to
interpret the term in a racist way he
insulted draymond green the same way
that he would insult anybody else
he treated draymond green as as equal
he didn't take his race into
consideration one way or another and for
that his entire career and his life will
be destroyed
and on that note his employer released a
statement shortly after the non-racist
racist tweet went viral saying during
saturday's memphis grizzlies game
meteorologist joey celipe tweeted a
comment that does not reflect the values
of fox 13. we take this matter very
seriously and we'll take appropriate
action pending a full investigation
translation he's gone
and i'll never work in the industry ever
again
powerful people in the nba have already
set out to make sure
of that part of it green's coach the
leftist goober steve kerr actually
addressed the tweet during his post-game
press conference and here's what he said
does it surprise me that a weatherman
would tweet a slur at draymond
in 2022 not in the slightest bit this is
this is america this is this is how we
operate
a slur like is that so we're going with
that now
so we could call it the k word
are we gonna get bleeped out if you say
knuckle dragger now
and kerr once again bravely speaking out
about the important issues of our time
such as a weatherman's tweet
steve stevecar he loves to give his
opinion and run his knuckle-dragging
mouth about many subjects that is unless
you ask him about the nba's relationship
with china that's when he suddenly gets
very shy
he'll bravely denounce a weatherman in
memphis but as for the communist
government of china which his company's
in business with he has much less to say
nothing at all to say in fact
now be that as it may kerr is right
actually
he says that this is what america is and
uh and this is what we we do here and
he's correct um that this is what we do
here at least it's what he does here
along with his leftist compatriots and
the media
what they do is entertain themselves and
advertise their own faux virtue and
exercise their cultural power by
destroying the lives of random hapless
patsies like this weatherman
much like they did with the okay sign
they've now simply invented
a racial slur out of whole cloth
they've decided arbitrarily that knuckle
dragger is racist anybody who uses it in
the future or who use it in the past
because these rules could be enforced
retroactively of course
must face the consequences your intent
doesn't matter
they will determine your intent
they will decide
why you said what you said
they get to assign motivation and
meaning to your to your statements after
the fact
does that can be any discussion about it
they will tell you what you meant
and you will accept it
at least if you're foolish and
self-destructive you'll accept it and as
far as that goes solopec is uh trying to
kind of have his cake and eat it too as
far as the apologies go this is a common
mistake that people in this situation
make before deleting his social media he
issued a statement that attempts to
defend himself against the racism charge
while still apologizing for it so he
tweeted
anyone who knows me knows what i am race
is never an issue to me
to anybody who was offended i apologize
but there was no ill intent
well of course there was no ill intent
obviously you didn't mean it in a racist
way we know you didn't mean it that way
because the term is in fact not a racial
slur we also know you didn't mean it
that way because even if you were a
raging racist you wouldn't set your life
and career on fire by advertising the
fact on twitter
well that's another thing that's always
left out of these conversations of you
know someone says something oh it was
racist
like in this fantasy world where this
guy's racist why would he say that
so you're saying he's not only racist
but he's psychotic on top of it
because in order to to be a
a person
anywhere but especially a public figure
with any kind of platform and to say
something intentionally racist
that is racist against black people as a
white person of course we know if you're
saying racist people things about white
people that you can totally get away
with it but to do it the other way
you you would not only have to be racist
but you would also have to be a psycho
you would have to be a lunatic
setting your whole life on fire for
no personal benefit
so we all know that's not what happened
here everyone who's pretending to be
offended knows that
um the people in the media writing all
of these headlines defaming him they all
know this
steve kerr knows it
nobody's hurt
nobody's offended
and even if they are offended who cares
joey you didn't do anything wrong
there's nothing to apologize for by
apologizing you admit guilt even while
in the next breath denying guilt
you have to pick a lane and the lane you
pick should be the one where you punch
the cry bullies in the mouth and tell
them to get lost
so here's a statement you should have
issued joe you should have said
i called draymond green a knuckle
dragger because i wanted to imply that
he's stupid and obnoxious which he is
the same could be said about the
outraged mob lying about me and calling
the racist i do not believe that any of
you drama queens and funnies are
actually offended and whether you are or
aren't i do not apologize god bless
that's the correct response
in fact draymond green himself
interestingly reacted to the apology on
instagram after the game by saying don't
apologize stand on it
now in context he didn't mean this as
actual encouragement or advice his real
point was simply to amplify the story so
as to further ruin celipe's life but
however insincere his advice was it was
also solid
he's right don't apologize stand on it
never bow to the knuckle draggers in the
cancel mom well i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt well show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content